The 1932 Olympics in Los Angeles the
scene is the Coliseum and the world's
outstanding athletes are here Mildred
Babe Didrikson making the javelin do
some travelin' 143 feet plus
a new world record for Babe
Plastic discus heave with Lillian Copeland during
the tossing another record 133 feet 2 inches
Good going gal now it's Ed
Gordon of the University
of Iowa and a 25 foot 3/4 inch leap that's Gordon
now let's watch as Leo Sexton
former Georgetown star makes
his bid in the shot foot sections
competing from York Athletic Club
at his winning toss measure 62 feet
plus for another new Olympic mark
it's the hammer throw now with Ireland
Dr. Patrick O'Callahan when they put the
tape to this one they'll find it travelled
176 feet 11 and 1/8 inches that's that Pat
the finals in the hundred meters
sprint with the runners bunched at
the start it Ed Tolan of Michigan in the
foreground edging in front of Metcalfe of
Marquette and holding his lead to win by
a whisker and ten and three ten seconds
a new Olympic record for Tolan